yeah but let's get a speedrun game in
that's for another stream everybody
ready
we're 2102.
i want to thank everybody as the
game is sought here for all the support
on the youtube it's incredibly
appreciated
[Music]
okay so obviously
okay 20 2014
okay so d4 and c3 that's
that's a move
and
it's a potential transposition to a
london system if the bishop comes out to
f4 it's a flexible way of getting a
couple of different setups
i feel like playing a king's indian
setup today so that's what we're gonna
do
i feel like playing a king's indian
setup let's play my real opening here
okay so now that tells me that was a
mouse slip but we basically got a king's
indian attack now which is hilarious
we're playing we're playing a king's
indian attack from the black side so
what you can envision what you can
imagine is
let's just open up another board so for
example
we have this position
we literally have this position and i'm
gonna treat this like a king's indian
attack
um so for instance we could play a
grunfeld
um
bishop g2 and knight c6 so this is the
position on the board right now
now i'm going to make a move that i'm
going to explain after the game we're
not going to play a pure king's indian
we're going to play a grunfeld up a
tempo the grunfeld is a very dynamic
opening i've played it before and it
makes a lot of sense to play it if you
have an extra tempo because uh because
your opponent might not be able to keep
uh keep his center
intact if he's down a tempo so bishop f4
is is a legitimate move
and for the time being we simply castle
and if white plays e3 then in grunfeld's
spirit we strike in the center
so
one of the most important
things about the grunfeld is that you
don't just let your opponent build up a
very solid pawn center you need to
attack it with your pawns strategically
what does it mean to attack the grenfell
center with pawns well here we have a
move that looks very crazy it looks like
ah you know you're just blundering all
of your pawns but in reality if you
understand the intricacies of the ground
field it makes a lot of sense
so what move am i talking about here you
can kind of play if you're a grunfeld
player you play this kind of move
without any calculation
yeah c5
um
if you're not a gunfield player this
move should look
weird to you like aren't we giving up a
pawn is this justified but as i'll show
you after the game it actually is it's
justified even if you're not up a tempo
h3 jesus
okay this guy is not playing well
um one of the other
important things about the grunfeld is
that you don't necessarily want to
release the tension until you have to so
i think there's a temptation to take on
d4 here
but for the time being i simply want to
develop my pieces and maintain the pawn
cube and see what happens what can we
get from it so let's just develop our
knight to c6
um
and on this level i've talked many times
about the importance of sort of keeping
the tension as long as you can
and then releasing it only when
you know when the time is ripe
so let's keep following that principle
who can suggest just imagine that
nothing is happening in the center what
would you do
if
let's say white's pawn was on c2 rather
than on c4
how would you play like if forget that
the pawn cube is there that'll help you
clarify your vision of the position you
would just develop a piece right well is
there any pieces left to develop yeah
there is
there's a bishop let's develop it right
i mean this is not rocket science let's
just go bishop f5 even bishop b6 was
interesting but
uh queen b62 queen b6 i like a lot
and now after bishop b2
we can do something pretty clever
um and what we can do
is start by taking on d4 and you'll see
why in a second
and i assume he's going to take back
with the pawn
what have we made him do we've made
white develop
their bishop
once
already and now by taking on c4 we force
white to lose a tempo i have talked
about this technique before
does that make sense so rather than
taking on c4 and allowing the bishop to
take from f1 we basically forced white
into losing a move and we have used this
move to develop our bishop
all right so now we have an iqp
situation
not a particularly desirable one for for
white
how should we play here
i'm thinking of a move that brings a
piece into the game
and actually creates a tactical threat
i'm thinking of several such moves
several such moves are possible
there was a previous suggestion
there was a previous suggestion that i
like which is queen b6 the other one is
rook c8 let's just play rook c8 let's
play it calmly x-raying the bishop
creating a threat of knight takes d4
potentially yeah queen b6 is also
excellent maybe even better
but i want to play this game in sort of
a
non-two you know not too crazy
positional style
and if he drops the bishop back to b3
already we can start sinking our teeth
into into some weak squares a knight
before multipurpose move
where is the knight going potentially
back to d5 in order to blockade the
square in front of the pawn we know how
important that is
but most probably it's going out to d3
even if he castles
it creates a fork against the bishop and
the pawn on b2
um and we're going to take that pawn and
then
what's that going to do other than win a
pawn well it's also going to weaken the
knight on c3 and our knight is not going
to have any trouble getting back it can
go back through c4 it can get back to d3
and look what we've made him do we made
him go bishop c1
another passive move so black is
i would say quite a bit better here but
nothing crazy
bishop c1 is is probably the best move
do we need to take this bishop
just yet
the answer to that question is no
because it's not really going anywhere
so let's keep putting our foot on the
gas pedal see if we can apply some more
pressure on him
and it turns out that we can we can play
moves such as queen b6 maybe not the
best move
but this is the kind of move that just
applies a little bit more pressure we
get the queen out to a good square
you know x-ray the b2 pawn maybe stop
him from dropping the bishop back to c2
trying to
to keep
you know to keep white confined but
i have to credit his defense he's he's
playing this pretty solidly so far
all right
no white's not getting crushed um
yeah knight h4 i was a little bit
worried about
and if we take on d4 then he takes on f5
ruins our structure a little bit and
then gets the bishop back out to e3
d6 there
let me think
i'm trying to figure out if it's worth
taking the pawn on d4 or not
i can't really tell the alternative is
to take on
c1 then we allow him to take on f5 and
a lot of our advantage evaporates there
you know what
let's see what happens let's take on d4
let's play it in principled fashion
takes takes i'm not worried about our
king safety because we've got the fiance
bishop white doesn't have anything going
on the king's side i'm a little bit
concerned about this pin
although
we have the capacity to defend the
knight if necessary with the move rook
after d8 it should be three now we have
to find a savvy square to drop our queen
to where it's not going to be subject to
more attacks if that makes sense
so for example if we were to play queen
uh d7
then we are subject subjecting ourselves
to
another attack
but that actually might be a good thing
and i'll explain that after the game i
have to speed up a little bit
we are going to play queen d7
so who can tell me how white can attack
the queen again
thank you otterfall
can white hit the queen and maybe he
will do that before people answer that
question
yeah bishop a4 so why are we allowing to
hit our queen because i would rather the
bishop be on a4 than on b3 when the
bishop is on b3 it's pinning the f7 pawn
it's creating discomfort and it's on a4
it's in the middle of nowhere sorry it's
in the middle of nowhere it's
susceptible to knight takes b2 which
would essentially fork it so trying to
get him to to weaken his position
queenie two excellent move
this guy is the real deal
um
but
now we've got the opportunity to bring
our knight back
but if we're really clever i think we
have an even better move
who sees
a possible tactic here
it's not easy to spot
it might not work but we're going to try
it
but only if people find it
yeah four is interesting but i think
white can just take on a7 there
yeah knight takes b2 is what i'm
thinking
we're in the territory already where
these games are not easy even for me
it's even if i were to play silently
like our opponents are good
so these kinds of tactics are required
to win games at this level
queen takes b2 and then knight e4
trying to win back the knight on c3 via
the pin
not that hard to see if you understand
the power of the grenfell bishop and
what it can do
that's entirely possible i miscalculated
something where i miss some resource
in fact
now i saw that you can throw in rook a
to d1 but that doesn't impact i think
the mechanism of the
attack provided that you place your
queen correctly
where should we place the queen
in order to reinforce the pressure
against the knight
well we could talk it back on e8 there's
something to be said for that
but i like the idea of putting it on c7
and hitting the knight one more time
with the queen or queen c6 yeah queen c6
he has a crazy resource knight d5
the idea being to take on e7 and then
win the queen back so
there are a lot of complicated tactics
here
some of which i'll delve into after the
game
um
and those of you who are maybe a little
bit lower rated or beginners and you're
watching this thinking like
discouraged thinking is this what chess
looks like at a high level it's just all
tactics well
um a lot of it is going to become clear
you know once you slow down a little bit
and you know my point is that everybody
can understand how these tactics work
even if you can't necessarily find them
in your own games yet but you will be
able to
if you keep at it
but don't worry too much about the
details right now i'll explain them
afterward
try to follow the general arc of the
game
all right
so
how should we do this now remember that
we're already up a couple of pawns so
we want to operate with an eye towards
simplifying the position
and the key question is do we take that
knight on c3 first or
do we take on d4 first and then take
maybe queen takes e3 well we're thinking
about achieving maximum number of trades
we would love to trade the queens
does either of these options enhance the
opportunity of trading queens yes if we
take on d4 first we force the rook out
into the center that looks like a good
thing for white
but in fact it isn't because we play
queen takes e3 this is essentially a
trade fork
uh we're forking the queen and the rook
and thereby forcing him to trade queens
now which way should we take who which
way should we take
i'll give you a hint
think not about creating a one move
threat think about a defense against the
rook infiltration to d7
we should take with the rook to keep
control the c file
most importantly against rook d7 which
he's about to play we have the move
knight c5 this is a crucial resource
without it we would have been losing one
of our extra pawns
this holds everything together because
if he takes on e7
we take the bishop twice and we have two
extra pawns in a rook end game that
should be winning
not the easiest end game to convert but
we should be able to do it
if he goes rook c7 that's not it that's
not scary we just go e6 i don't think
anything can be squeezed out of that pin
and then we slowly improve our position
still not easy but doable
why do i go e6 well to defend that pawn
and to blunt
that bishop
we could have done without that move but
the knight is in no imminent danger
worse comes to worse it can be protected
with b6
he's probably gonna go rook d1 would be
my guess
now then we have to think about how to
make progress on the queen side if he
goes rook d1 we don't have the
opportunity to activate the stroke just
yet
we don't have the opportunity to move
the knight we can move it to e4 but then
we blunder b7 so we really only have one
option which is to push our pawns
and
try to force some sort of weakening in
white's position we are actually
threatening a4 that would trap the
bishop
that would trap the bishop
um
oh yeah i could take on b3 but there
wasn't a fork on d2 in the end the rooks
were not forkably positioned
all right so i i hope
this is making
some degree of sense by the way
i mean
obviously
all right
rook d4
that is the decisive one now in such
positions i always talk about pins as
being a two-way street
people think of pins as a one-way street
if you're pinned you think ah now that's
bad for me a pin is always a two-way
two-way device because the piece that's
doing the pinning
can always end up being the victim in a
different set of circumstances does that
make sense
so the rook on c7 it's doing the pinning
technically
but the knight
has a spring-loaded mechanism here of
delivering some sort of a discovery and
that's exactly what we do here we take
on b3 it turns out that the rook on d4
is vulnerably positioned the knight is
attacking it this move was impossible
earlier
because
he would have just taken on c3 but now
of course we take on d4 we're up a piece
and we're winning the game
how do you know to look for this well
any time that there is a pin
and the pinned piece is undefended you
should always look for discoveries
thank you montana good to see you
any time that
any time that um
that
you have a pin situation and your
opponent's pinning piece is unprotected
you should look for
you should never assume that your pin
piece cannot move
um
unless of course it's pinned to the king
in which case it legally cannot move
yes so it's being uploaded to my youtube
i'd be honored if people subbed
okay rook c4 i mean the rest is very
easy just take it and the knight is
easy to evacuate we can do it through d2
and e4
yeah it's over
it is over
yeah rook c1 and knight be through is
also possible but
there was no necessity for that let's
try to preserve our pawns no need to
give any of them away unless we have to
and now the rest is straightforward
that's another thing i often see
uh with with you know some inexperienced
players and it's understandable
i always talk about you know when you're
up material you want to give some of it
up sometimes in order to simplify the
process but what that doesn't mean is
that you should
deliberately give up material
when you don't have to here we don't
have to we can preserve all of our pawns
now we have a really sexy move here
that ends the game immediately it
embarks on a maneuver
wins the game what was the idea of f3
well he was trying to stop us from
coming to e4 and c3
but if we ask ourselves can we achieve
the idea in a different way
and we find the move knight b1
doesn't seem to matter now because we're
up a piece but it's it's important to
play precisely when possible
and the knight comes to c3 and that's
the death blow for white because he's
going to lose a2
and then our pawns are going to decide
the game
and the funny thing is the rook can't
even come back to e2 the knight is
totally dominating the rook here
always nice when you put one of your
pieces on a square where your opponent's
piece was once set up here we could take
okay let's take on g4 first just for the
sake of
precision
again
no need to
give anything up we can be greedy
and now it's resignable our pawns just
steamroll down the board
yeah without the no without the rook
it would probably be closer to a draw
because it's hard to get the pawns
rolling
okay so this is a great example of okay
we don't need to keep both pawns anymore
because one of them promotes i don't
know why he's not resigning
but so basically we played this game
with white
yeah good game
and we're 90 points away from the speed
runs conclusion
all right
so
in retrospect it's clear that this was a
mouse slip
um
but the way that i should have played
this is to convert it into a london with
bishop f4 like that's what
i think
that's what i think
uh white should have done
and um bishop g7 knight d2 and which
basically transposed into a london so c3
is not a bad move uh it's actually quite
flexible you could even transpose into
the tory attack with bishop g5
or you could play something calm like g3
which is which is also a respectable
line although it's not dangerous
but clearly this guy insisted
knight c3 and we changed course with d5
alright so
the point of this is that if white plays
as white would play in the grunfeld's it
takes an e4
this is the main line of the grunfeld so
if you
talk about the grunfeld
most of the time white takes and plays
e4
and then black takes and develops the
bishop
the idea is to mount a quick assault on
white's center with c5
but if you think about okay now we have
an extra tempo
and that extra tempo makes
a very big
difference in this position if we
already have the bishop pre-developed
pre-get we can go c5
um
and white center crumbles pretty damn
quickly
white center crumbles pretty damn
quickly what does tempo mean tempo
literally means time in italian but it's
it's uh it's actually a hard thing to
define but it
it's the sense of time or the sense of a
move in chess
so when you play a move with tempo it's
a move that is played
with a threat and so that buys you time
because your opponent essentially has to
respond to it that's the idea so i've
had i've had a game like this with the
white pieces where
i was essentially able to force decisive
weaknesses
in my opponent's center very quickly and
then get into an awesome end game
i was playing white so i i basically
played the reverse grunfeld
and my opponent went into like the main
line
but what very quickly happens here is
white piles on the pressure that extra
tempo does all of the difference
black has to play the movie for
what is the positional flaw of this move
who can tell me that what's the what's
the problem with a move like e4 in fact
this is a huge problem
and black's position from a strategic
standpoint i know this sounds crazy but
it's almost already lost
no we don't want to play f3
it weakens this very important d4 square
so what we basically do is we create a
blockade on that square and we freeze
black's pawn chain and this pawn on d5
particularly becomes permanently weak
regardless of the position so that's a
weakness black is going to be saddled
with for the rest of the game
and what i did was i simply went into an
endgame i played queen a4
takes takes rook fd1
i got my knight over to d4 because
that's the best square to blockade
then i said i have one more problem left
to solve my bishop is bad let's get it
back to f1 so it does something
we traded a bunch of pieces there's that
bishop and
the rest of the game is pretty simple
you just play a3 before you create a
passer and eventually i ground my
opponent down it wasn't perfect but
but uh it was pretty simple actually
by the way um
if you're paying careful attention you
might think naiji iv
was blundered by both sides but it
wasn't
what did i intend against nichi for
and again on defended pieces come to the
rescue here
it's bishop h3 pin the knight then you
trade the night and you have a classic
good night against bad night bad bishop
situation so anyways it doesn't matter i
know i spent a long time on this but
that's the bottom line that's what
happens if white plays the main line so
i think his decision to play bishop f4
is a good one
e3 c5
and again we're following the main line
of the grunfeld with an extra tempo if
dc
we can swing our queen out to a5 pin the
knight
and after c takes d5 we could even play
knight takes d5 with simple tactics
takes takes and white is in deep yogurt
in fact white is completely lost here
because
if bc then queen c3 with a fork if the
king comes out well i'll let you guys
figure out what happens there
no no the reverse grunfeld is not great
for whites so very few people play it
so i guess that white played pretty
prudently h3 knight c6
knight f3
and bishop f5 developing the bishop
keeping the tension
again of dc we have queen a5 same exact
mechanism the rook is always going to be
undefended in the corner
so bishop b2
cd eddc we force his bishop to move
twice thank you from gelato
get the rook into the game i think queen
b6
uh was was was a better idea and the
engine confirms that queen b6 was more
far more accurate than rook c8
because it just does more it attacks the
pawn immediately rook ca was too general
and if
it's not easy to defend this pawn how
does how does white defend this pawn
because
if um
i mean rook b1 is not possible because
some genius developed their bishop to f5
yeah i mean h3
i think h3 is not bad on second thought
but had i played queen b6 what would
have been a big trouble
yeah well if white plays b3 well that is
the effect of weakening the knight on c3
we could also park our rook on d8
and white's position simply starts
falling apart here
that's the problem same with queen d2
white's position just starts falling
apart
rook d1 we could swing in 94.
you guys should all be able to see just
i mean look at look at how many pieces
are attacking that d4 pawn white's
position is about to just bust open
so it's not so much the problem of the
b2 pawn is that we're going to play rook
d8 and 94 and
crush white to pieces here
um rip so roxy8 is bad that's that's
that's not a move i should have played
knight before castles and i'll be honest
i completely missed bishop c1
i i forgot this was a thing and
now i realize that okay if we take the
bishop we have the two bishops but
white's position is quite solid here
it's honestly not more not more than
equality because this bishop on b3 is
really nice it's sort of
x-raying the position and if we play e6
now this bishop is kind of stranded we
always have to deal with g4 so
uh a little bit superficial by me
now we play queen v6
but it doesn't have the same effect
because white's already castled
and knight h4 is
quite an interesting move
um
but i think that the simple queenie ii
would have
solved all of white's problems
the idea is to just play rook d1 and
eventually to force the knight smoke the
knight out of d3 force force me to take
and again you get this type of position
which i think is about equal
right
he plays more adventurously that queen
takes d4 takes takes bishop e3
and i really like the move queen d7 i
think this move caused
a lot of practical problems
and
the idea after bishop a4 queen ian as i
explained is that the bishop is very
misplaced on a4
if that makes sense now we're
threatening knight takes p2 so it's
unclear how white gets full compensation
for the pawn thank you zaisy for the
tier 2.
it's just unclear how to get full comp
for the pawn the computer gives knight
t5 as the only equalizing move
intercepting
the queen and the knight and after
knight d5 queen d3
this creates another pin
we can drop our knight back and defend
our queen
and after the simple queen e2 apparently
white has pretty good compensation the
rook comes to d1 why has an initiative
why does the two bishops fight as an
initiative
probably enough for equality if white's
accurate
instead queen e2 blunders knight takes
b2
how did i see this tactic thank you
shane kane gifting to brawling478 well
the bottom line here is that
um when you what does it even mean to
know an opening well to know an opening
means first and foremost to know some
main line theory
but another thing that's often
overlooked when people talk about
openings is to understand the role of
each piece
in an ideal setup
so if you're a kingzinian player for
example
you shouldn't just toss away the role
of the king's indian bishop on g7 you
should understand when it's good under
what circumstances
what tactics it's capable of that sounds
a little bit cheesy but
you should always try to do that if
you're a night or player with white
let's say you're a one e4 player
you want to learn
you know mainline knight or if you want
to learn the bishop g5 line
well in the main line one thing you
should be aware of is that this knight
often sacrifices itself on d5
in fact in most sicilians the idea of
the night sacrifice on d5 is a very
prominent one and you should be aware of
it
and by being aware of these things
you just greatly increase
your your ability to improvise in an
opening your ability to find cool ideas
so i'll give you another quick example
i had a really nice game that i played
some years
ago where
my opponent was a gm but basically in
this game
my opponent kept playing this line with
97
and
i
looked this up before the game
and i played a move which in 2013 was
barely played which is knight t5
and and basically
this gets this crazy position where i've
sacked a knight but i have this attack
down the iphone the reason i was able to
come up with it is that i was aware that
this id of 95 existed
in many types of positions
and i was able to win a very nice game
um i don't know how much of that you
heard but
we can go back to
back to the speed run the point i'm
trying to make is that you should try to
be aware of the role that each piece
plays if you know if you want to know an
opening really well
and so this bishop is really the hero of
this tactic this is called removing the
defender you're removing the pawn
and now the rest is easy you just pounce
with a bunch of different pieces
all right
here here
why not queen c6
queen c6
creates a forkable situation between the
king and the king king of the king king
and the queen
and after 95 um
bishop takes b2 white is able to
secure a pawn for the peace and maybe
infiltrate to d7 this creates
an unclear position sorry let me
let me do that on a different board
these small details that's what wins you
games wins and loses you games at this
level like not allowing knight t5
why is knight d5 not a thing here
because here we just take the queen and
take the knight
and there's no pawn loss to speak of
um does bishop take c3 work after rook
81.
it works in the sense that it doesn't
lose a piece and very good job seeing
queen take c3 queen takes d1 the problem
is just rook takes d7 and white starts
vacuuming up all these pawns on the
seventh rank which you don't want to
allow
so yeah you're absolutely on the money
and so that's why we should play queen
c7 bishop d4 probably hastens white's
defeat
probably white should go knight b5 or
knight t5 anyway
and snag upon an a7 try to hold this
position together down upon but it's
difficult
it's going to be difficult it's going to
be tremendous
um
takes takes takes takes and the rest is
easy rook d7 knight c5
e6 and now we're just two pawns up the
pawns start rolling
there's very little that white can do
about the threat of a4 the position's
already lost i just don't see how to
stop a4
the funny thing is after a4 bishop a4
our knight
is able to take the bishop and protect
the rook at the same time
important detail and of course rook d4
hastens the defeat after knight b3 the
game is over
so
i would say that the theme of this game
other than openings is
just tactical subtleties winning games
at this level two thousand twenty one
hundred
uh you just gotta be incredibly on your
heels
and and you gotta spot
small nuances within the position that
give you that that extra edge so
and that's where we're gonna end guys
so i'll do more speed running tomorrow
probably i'll do another stream midday
but for now i'm gonna hit the sack
i'm trying to stick to a better schedule
these days trying to get into the into
good form for the tournament so i'm
gonna raid
my great friend
min
and i will see you guys tomorrow i just
want to thank everybody for the
tremendous support particularly montana
i want to remind you that the
speedrun videos do come out reliably on
my youtube so if you give me a sub to
that i'd really appreciate it thank you
cooner
and rustan for the prime
and that's all she wrote guys
thank you for hanging out hope you had a
good time
and um i will see everybody
tomorrow have a great rest of your
weekend start your week
see you guys later
[Music]
you